foreign
the Kremlin says that the war is going
to plan
um
I'm not sure anybody else really
believes that and in Russia I think it's
now become acknowledged that this is a
tougher proposition than they imagined
back in February but in theory although
the acknowledgment is that mistakes have
been made there is no way the Russians
think they will not Prevail because
they're Russia they're a big Power
they've got a 144 million population a
big economy therefore once they put
their minds to it they will prevail and
the justifications for that it come and
go as as the months go on foreign
ly seem to believe that Russia is a
great power that it has not been
accorded the respect that it was due
that the United States is due to be
taken down and that NATO has got to be
shown where the boundaries are and so
underlying any doubts about this
conflict within the broader Russian
population there does seem to be a sense
that this is It's about time that Russia
asserted itself and that the world took
some notice now I suspect that that
opinion is rather brittle and that
failure on the kremlin's part will
quickly translate into a disillusionment
but until the Kremlin or Leicester
Kremlin absolutely fails in Ukraine that
sense that that Russia has a right to
pursue this operation to assert itself
in Europe I think goes very deep into
the Russian popular psychology
foreign
didn't fall
Ukraine is Alive and Kicking for the
ukrainians this is a war of national
survival simple as that there was an
idea before the war started that because
you know between 30 and 40 percent of
ukrainians spoke Russian president
zielinski his first language is Russian
there was a sort of belief in some parts
of the world and certainly in Russia
that the ukrainians would welcome the
Russians in accept the Russians in and
that Ukraine actually would adjust quite
quickly to effectively a Russian
takeover that hasn't been true at all
and one of the things that has been most
interesting about this whole conflict in
the fine in the last year is how
completely patriotic the vast vast
majority of ukrainians are that has
actually given Ukraine a sense of
nationhood that he does not possessed
for well over a hundred years and that
sense of nationhood I think will Propel
it to be a different sort of state after
this war the new Ukraine that emerges
from this War I think will be thirdly
European will be absolutely Westward
leaning and it knows it will have to
live with a hostile Russia for the next
Century or more but it's more than
prepared to do that because of this
discovery this feeling that they have
that they now have real nationhood
nationality and identity
as one the Battle of kirstan has won the
Battle of kharkiv Ukraine has defied
Russia's expectations at every single
turn so I think that the West has now
decided that the ukrainians are not just
losing slowly they're actually capable
of asserting their territorial Integrity
throughout most if not all of Ukraine
that will create a crisis in Russia but
the view now in the west is well that's
Russia's problem we can't influence that
if Putin is seen to fail in this
operation and he now can be seen to fail
it is viewed in the west then he will
have to do the consequences that's not
our responsibility and so I think
there's been a great hardening of
opinion in the west and far from being a
a sense of of fatigue over the Ukraine
war at least the leaderships of the
western Powers have remained remarkably
United over more or less a year of this
conflict